good thing hello welcome back to
resident knievel I'm Mike my hearty
we're back it's a very early on if well
10 a.m. on a Friday it's the only time
in our busy schedules that we can do
this we are back to this gonna be loud
we're back to a normal little screen
down here who is this I don't wanna
cover up any it was this hunky man it's
hot Marine Force Recon sent to be
execution the other ones at least they
were like dressed in police gear for the
most part so you've met her before
Rebecca and resonable won okay but this
guy this is the are you playing - this
looks like - player no so that's that's
this game very different whoa whoa so
whenever you're knocking whatever
character we're not controlling it's
gonna be a I control all there's explody
dudes and guess what there's no item
boxes in this game how do you you drop
items you've drop items on the ground
and they stay there on the map until you
pick them up later it's marked on your
map stupid it makes it it's more of a
survival game we're playing normal I
think that's what we've been doing when
we have the option yeah so this is the
debut episode of resident could evil
zero yeah and yeah you guys probably
noticed we have the our picture in the
lower right and that's because this game
has a different aspect ratio so we
actually can't have the previous way we
did it we got to go back to the original
mode if you want to look at it then we
can go back to the other way or we can
do sixteen by nine oh you started the
game yeah I did did you mean - no way ha
skip this touch bad maybe well I want to
start this soon I don't know we're gonna
get back out and change the break we'll
go to the other pit okay well I'll
change it when it comes off just
traumatic events traumatic events no it
is believed at the end I thought we had
to do it the other way but it turns out
we just didn't do enough research we're
usually so prepared yeah totally
we switched your rooms again oh no I
don't know if this is what we want no
not at all
so okay I don't know if you could change
a mid-game if not we'll just back out
restart [ __ ] just deal with our dumb
faces being smaller I just don't want
the game being no hits 16 by 9 oh I'm
sorry it's a 4 by 3 which means if you
go to the game pit oh it should be fine
hi we're back uh resonable purists out
there this section that might be better
because you're getting the original so
not tank controls that's right so uh
just to clarify if you hadn't already
been able to surmise from the graphics
I'm on a train we are yeah that we are
also playing the origins collection
right we're not paying the original this
is like an updated version this is also
the same disk we used for the inaugural
season of Knievel so this is kind of
full circle this is the same as a few
old
it feels so old give it a smell does it
smell old
yeah it smells like you in 2016 we start
like two years yeah oh wait what
episodes that's 98 we're getting there
it's either 98 or 99 yeah I can't
believe it
all right so I have Rebecca chambers 45
bullets I have one gun and that's it no
health what's what's the under personal
mixing set so that's her thing nothing
set so you can in this game you can swap
items between Billy and Rebecca oh I see
or drop them on the ground and then
whenever if you have both of them in
your party so to speak the other one
will be controlled by AI I don't know if
the AI was updated for the organ so are
you saying that he can't mix medicines
cuz that's a big deal but he can move
large objects and he has a lighter and
he can take more damage great
in that respect he's like Chris Redfield
yep all right
you turn the monitors like
keep that oh that's up to you okay so
she was in the first game when right
before Yann was it with the piano
related stuff mm-hmm so you are she's
part of some what I meant to do I meant
to look at the map but I think the
buttons are a bit different
so after Bravo teams helicopter crashed
she came to investigate the train which
was attacked by leeches which we will
soon find out or carrying the t-virus
I know these are okay this is just the
same stuff I was kind of hoping maybe
there was something in this but it's
just the same thing repeated so there's
nothing here so I'm gonna move on mm-hmm
for a 2002 GameCube game they did a
pretty good job updating how this looks
the ecliptic Express this was on its way
through the Arklay mountains when Bravo
Team was remember the helicopter crash
in the way to Spencer mansion yes
someone there is someone there
don't what's you
oh [ __ ] no I'm gonna take five
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
I think I'm thinking of tank controls
yeah so I'm trying to back up when I
just need to turn on all right it's not
a great start for Mary at least you're a
medic okay so I'm hurt you were you
started off whoa there's an abrupt
cutscene Nintendo didn't waste any time
sorry Capcom didn't waste any time it
doesn't - wow this looks really good
yeah it does look guy it looks really
nice um now unfortunately I'm hurt one
caution and I have no health I was kind
of hoping I would have acquired some
health but I did not so not not a great
start
no but we for not breaking from
tradition can I eat this plant no it's
like passenger cars okay let's check
that out people in the comments all
think you're gonna like Billy is he like
Steve if Steve was a Marine Force Recon
remember which may be you know the force
would come our badasses t-virus
Raccoon City murders the usual fare for
resident evil remember how much time we
took reading every single entry and
resonable 1 & 2 yes ooh bullets that's
good uno para bellum um that means
prepare for war his body is covered in
slime he's prepared for war on Italian
it's the rainbow 6 expansion ok let's it
well this looks really nice I must say
like the Welcome ever well it's a nice
detail this version of remake and then
we went to Brazil too right
which was kind of and it was super
jarring are there doors on this side
there's this here's another alright I'm
gonna go in this door first I'm really
looking for like some health at this
point I'm already injured and I want to
restart this game although it's not like
I'm that far typewriter ok so save a
plant that's great
so yeah you can't just like keep ink
ribbons in an item box we're not using
you gotta oh do I get three good
question I think so my usual practice
which people could correct me I usually
just leave them near the typewriters
because like if you're gonna be using
them right
she part of Alpha Team maybe or Bravo I
don't think she was gonna being sent to
well is it too early to save should I
just leave it there for now or say some
well actually pick those up so we can
see how the items stuff works sure it's
100 yes I shouldn't use it yeah so
alright let's look at you might not be
able to do three so got three I got oh
sorry my inventory system is off is
different okay got it
I just leave well not that handgun but
sorry no sorry the option under on the
menu called leave that's drops items so
should I drop my pucks yeah just so you
can see how it works
N+ so let's see where right there
they'll put a mere inconvenience pots
right there in the middle of the room oh
okay it's it's not like and then open
your map yeah I do have a map every map
not very good but yes I have so you can
see right there as the flashing red dot
so they show up on your maps say will
save stuff always be red or like no no I
think that's just an item it's just an
item it could be anything
yeah so that's where it comes that's
like where some memory comes into play
don't worry I got the memory the [ __ ]
aardvark what movie people know this yes
if my brilliant guidance through code
veronica was any indication my memory is
that of a hawk yes another animal known
for their memory you you really liked
Code Veronica that was also I did I
really it was it was pretty hard I think
when I look back on it just the train
key okay oh noes oh no that's a he does
a regular man ooh
regular you think Billy's Rahal he's not
a zombie Snake Plissken Harry
lieutenant Cohen so you seem to know me
this isn't been fantasizing about me
Wow was being transferred for execution
you are with those soldiers outside oh I
see you're with Stars
well no offense huh it is like your kind
doesn't seem to want me around goats so
I'm afraid our little chat time is over
wait you're under arrest
whoa zorax doll face doll face oh when
you you know it Billy looks like he eats
bullets for breakfast yeah he did Billy
do that
oh he's jumped through the window you
must be careful
she's Alpha Team I think she's Bravo I'm
sorry this is the lure obsessed side
with me is getting curious on these
monsters it bears oh my oh oh oh oh no
the doges not a dog you know I feel that
dogs
that's [ __ ]
her handgun seems pretty powerful yeah
it does I like it
the music's still hot Oh dope it's like
a monkey
[Music]
I love that look at the rain coming
through the window oh then I don't think
that was there in the original maybe
well yeah dog yeah you let's concentrate
on the fight first you're right
and the stairs knock back with the
handgun yes dogs in this game it's
really nice like even there's the
intestines this game looks very good
people are so happy just a few hours ago
killing zombies me no gotcha
yeah go ahead Mike yeah I was just
looking up Laura stuff I was gonna say
away is this a safe room
you're like a chamber she is part of
Bravo Team yeah this is the same room
what I was gonna say was Bobby reminds
me of like an old western or like
classic mmm like sorry girl it's just
nothing I could do that stud yes we
haven't seen Mikey in a long time
actually cuz every time we saw like a
jet or a helicopter last episode it was
us flying it hmm I don't think there's a
Mikey here we could call Billy Mikey the
whole game where did this [ __ ] come
from when did there become more in here
[Music]
I'm more worried about the seizure he's
had I did I'm okay I don't think he's
dead
nice
you got the train keys yes there was a
locked door back yeah this way ish right
I can't okay so I hold it for [ __ ]
sake sorry I'm like getting adjusted to
the okay so there was a lot of different
locked areas and I can't honestly
remember which one the key was supposed
to go to so you got the Train key it was
on the far left
yes I'm assuming that means it's all the
way on the other side that's what I
thought that was my into that's the way
Billy was walking before the dogs pop in
and their stairs right there by the way
that you haven't used yet whoa
oh [ __ ] don't go up here yet well no
that was my fault
I'll say picture curiosity I'm sorry um
you're fine yeah just that stuff I don't
know if you don't get it yet um no you
can get the herb I'm just saying like
those mushroom things yeah so don't walk
on the mushrooms I don't even think you
can I might just leave the planet like I
if I'm gonna come back so I think you
actually are going the right way but
like but there's stuff going on up here
I'm just saying sorry I played a little
bit over the weekend I'm I'm so Cove
Veronica I didn't play at all I actually
liked doing the blind playthrough but I
did wanna I just was interested in
playing this game but I don't want
through the door that we haven't gone
through yet come on no zombies Wow was
all these men so many men characters
[Music]
20 Oh Billy has called him Bobby
so he's mentally ill he crazy
that's this game's not particularly
sympathetic to the to the what just
mental illnesses oh yeah from what I
remember all right although I would
venture a guess that most Marine Force
Recon members are not mentally ill after
they come back from she has tattoos
though Billy yeah he looked really good
he had those flames going on oh yeah
like the Celtic flames a little bit
tribal [ __ ] did you hear that yeah um I
just realized I haven't combined my
bullets my gun so if there's [ __ ] going
down in here I'm not gonna I'm not
prepared oh god oh god it's gonna be
dangerous from here on in hey doll face
why don't we cooperate cooperate with
you it's a cooperative game Rebecca
there's some things on this trip and I
for one want to get out of here I don't
think we stand a chance doing it alone
you expect me to trust you a wanton
Ellen I don't need your help kind of
looks like bono my own like 1989 bono
get her to do it yourself what should I
call you the name is Rebecca chambers
yeah that's right officer chambers T
that's right well then Rebecca right why
don't you go and try while I wait here
where's the edge
she told him oh wait he likes kept her
yeah so she's stuck this is where I like
women feel standoffish with men
they're like walk you in hey I was being
nice to you doll face but now I'm just
gonna like stop you from moving
progressively because I want to
intimidate the [ __ ] out of you I guess
I'll use your name to talk to you well
he's not the most welcome person I
wouldn't use the word bloke when
describing Billy
mm to Billy was kind of peaceful yeah
you could say that lock uh yeah glass
ceiling was a little lower but then this
fire
said her so would you like a refill on
your water is bread free two orders a
salad bottomless excuse me sir
Olive Garden does that sir Oh
[Music]
they just want to run oh don't shoot it
all right it's up to you all right
wait no I didn't mean to do that
can I take him down with him again yeah
I believe so he can hit me from so far
away yeah
Oh Oh
die die no that part's just kind of
nebulous cuz he's supposed to save you
but like if you I don't know I've always
[ __ ] yeah
hell yes nothing says resin can evil
like this [ __ ] guy
well minus the misogyny I think there's
that's like part of it like an evil
there's elements of it and almost every
day oh I thought you meant
no I meant resident can you the show
ingrained into the series not the show
though no son Wow look at this
[Music]
whoa who is that oh he's pretty
good-looking them I'll say who is that
guy
Oh jelly I thought I was the
best-looking one in this game tuff
welcome to the objectification of men
Billy we gotta cooperate with each other
from now on I got that like literally
the game makes us girl clue in girls he
did just save you you just remember I
will shoot you if you try anything funny
fine now take these with you oh that was
nice if you find anything give me a call
all right
with this
okay so now we're friends yeah that's
good
also the loading screen is those worm
things about loading icon' Chris you can
switch control between Rebecca and Billy
using their different abilities progress
cool the character you currently control
is the main character of the canotary
you do not control is called the partner
the partner character generally moves
independently but you can use R to
control them yourself
okay selecting partner on the status
screen allows you to assign instructions
to the character so they can either move
independently or I can make them follow
me attack partner attacks automatically
idle partner will not attack you can
also press the d-pad or whatever the
touchpad to switch between solo and team
press triangle at the status screen okay
there's a lot going on
okay so Rebecca can combine herbs she
has weak defense and she's a mixing set
to combine chemicals chemicals Billy
cannot combine that's not an attribute
it's just not an attribute you should
just not have that honor it's a lack of
an attribute he's strong and he's got a
tattoo both a main character and partner
die if they take too much damage you
should always keep an eye on their
condition if no hold on go back okay if
the partner characters attacked both the
main and partner characters will die
okay so you're saying like you have to
worry about both their Health's got it
even if you're not playing as Billy if
he gets messed up you'll double you both
he can he get hurt he just can't die I
just have to manage his health as well
got it
a partner being attacked in a different
room will call for help if your partner
does call go to help as quickly as
possible some puzzles cannot be solved
by only one character there's a lot of
that okay Wow
it's it's less like on so honestly like
I've I'm sure a lot of most of that if
not all of it made sense but like this
game is probably the most modern and in
terms
this kind of design like I think a lot
of this will feel a more like modern
game to you
so he's following me right now you can
also control him with the right analog
stick if you want to be more specific to
what his movements but from what I
remember is check his room first I
thought there were items maybe not oh
there's that green no that was the other
upstairs sorry this it that's it the
only thing we could do so you move
around practice yeah oh [ __ ] I'm in
danger
okay I'm gonna eat this thing wait am I
on Billy or am I on me you're on you
okay so that's just saying his list of
commands is up because you're not
controlling him so you could tell him
what to do so press l1 yeah he's also
got a different handgun 1911 combat
knife okay but I want her to eat this
mm-hmm so I'm not giving this to Billy
correct although yeah so so l1 like Idol
is you would set him to not attack solo
our team he's following because it's on
team and then change is when you switch
to him
Shai change to him you don't have to yet
but that's how you would do it and then
can exchange go that can exchange
oh you can't okay that just means oh
he's your able to swap items with him
right now if you wanted to got it so you
can share ammo this is like what game do
we play well I mean I guess it's like it
okay so I could like take his stuff yes
but you're also gonna have to control
him okay okay well I got it it can make
things harder this system but I can also
make things easier it's more survival
inventory focus I'm going up to the roof
Tom Hanks is up there drinking coffee oh
god that's a good movie Oh
chocolate hot I don't think there's
anything for me to do up here maybe
there is
okay okay check the check the spark
thing first
I can't D can't just go around
I go around
the power cable has been disconnected
reconnect the cable is that gonna
electrocute me no I can see why you'd be
worried about that yeah it's not like
you're covered in water when you did
that the power cord just nevermind oh
good another plan
Oh the kitchen so Bobby isn't here Billy
he's upstairs
mr. doll you shake Dolph
mr. doll it's called the service lift
hey hey it's how that's tiny he's not
gonna fit there can you though Billy get
in the service elevator you must be a
woman to ride this elevator I need to
know where it goes first
yeah I doubt it goes to the top of the
Train Oh a train gee that's nice
inspect it I think there's like more to
these keys that you're not inspecting
chain what button brings up the menu
items the inventory in this game by the
way because touchpad switches to
inventory is square but I select with X
whereas before I would like kind of see
options with square so I keep
accidentally leaving conductor room so
back out and press the touchpad I came
over with a said that does switches to
the other character you have to be in
the same room right okay cool okay so
that's it for now
[Music]
and I can't get back uh oh okay I need
the knife from so yeah so that idiot
okay so alright so when he can I talk to
him from here maybe can you not change
the him go change I think you just need
to be him and go find that that one yeah
there you go
you should be him now and you've got a
lighter keep in mind with him can I get
in there I believe so I don't know so
you have to double back and then find
that door I do believe so yeah because
member you can go through that door that
you were blocking earlier yeah you're
you now oh my god this is what it feels
like to be all-powerful
the Train is kind of phallic hope that I
just have
yes we down below like handcuffs on I
like it it's a nice little touch and
it's kinky learning a lot about Mikey
today I don't know how useful his knife
is that might be worth experimenting
with cuz it'll take damage so if you
want to conserve ammo maybe chop at the
knees chop on their knees let's see
do you mind I'm not saying it's good I'm
just saying I don't know but also look
at him he looks at really hot um yeah I
was wait how do i that open Oh cuz you
turn the power on
wait use me hold on a second what's in
that pan right there cooking is that the
little worm things do you see that so
it's hard to tell but I don't think
anything's cooking I just think because
the train is wobbly wobbly sorry no like
what look there's something cooked past
tense I mean it could be avocado that's
burnt I have one more question why do I
care this much about that
oh the ovens on when we played six we
were like see what that is that elevator
dumbwaiter oh hello
oh I went in it no I did not only give
it you not do with a knife can't use I
get a key or something
oh you know what
I accidentally unequipped my knife
sometime okay I'm just gonna
so is this room like nothing you go back
there okay yes so sorry that the the
other thing I thought the other thing
was the service left that's what I meant
I'll put my knife in there and then
she'll get the knife got it okay I
understand I don't see why you couldn't
just drop it in the hole yeah like I
understand what do you mean the item is
too large oh maybe you have to find like
a lockpick or something no that wouldn't
make sense what are you saying huh
that's weird
really I just wanted to see if it worked
yeah give me my [ __ ] back so I can't
send the knife I'm a little confused
that really felt like what the game was
trying to teach me let's try again
okay I can't send my it doesn't matter
that it's equipped so oh I don't think
so because saying it's too large right
I'll try anyway or we're just missing an
item maybe you're right maybe there
maybe there's like a knife as you can
also go back the way you came where he
was blocking they said that there wasn't
anything of value here
that's the way equip your handgun and
then try to sure sure it's just that it
said it was too large not yeah that it
would be use I agree but it's worth
trying it's where you put a handgun
rounds in there but not that night yeah
I guess we just didn't find what we need
yet
okay well let's let's investigate the
train and see if we can find a knife
I guess that's so weird are you sure
that I'm not just was to drop it in that
hole yeah yeah okay that would be the
logical thing for ability to do but it
really makes things more difficult than
they need to be so handsome
so dumb Billy okay get on the ground you
pick idiot here like Lud that's
something Billy would say gotcha [ __ ]
walk yeah get back up
fight me like a zombie man oops too high
the bag booby Vuitton Billy just really
into fashion as well
he's just keep letting people that come
back to life it's really annoying so I'm
looking for a knife or a sharp object or
also alternatively alternatively he can
move large objects so maybe there's
something that he can move to gets it
well what's that is that just the window
say right
hmm okay good to know
I heard is aam I huh looked like a
timeout I was pretending to be Billy
same time out when he was reloading is
he gonna give a good nice put me laid
blood out I'm running out of bullets
mm-hmm so I'm gonna switch to my knife
game for the knees I think I don't know
if this game is the same okay
through that Dory just a walk I think
these are locked oh yeah that's like an
exit I'm not sure what I'm doing I'm not
like you know disappointed about it I
just don't really know what's going on
so these are just the same rooms that's
the save room
[Music]
oh I have the key for that oh [ __ ] oh
session yeah okay but I can't she's
supposed to send the key oh [ __ ] we did
it opposite I was trying to get her out
I'm so doctor then all right I'll be
something sharp in there okay we've just
been doing it the opposite yeah all
right that's fine so theoretically if he
wants you could switch to her it now and
put it in there and then come back to
Billy and walk or but I mean I don't
think it it doesn't matter yeah I think
either way I have to go through this
process now all right well I've so that
makes a tiny bit more sense like if she
wished to throw the key up through the
hole it might just get off the train and
they'd be stuck forever
I understand see this game is actually
really intelligent problem existed with
us game smart player dumb married um I
knew the whole time I was just testing
you
okay so I'm gonna switch humans now okay
now I'm you and I'm going to with me go
into here
we're so silly it's like all clicking
now yes I'd like to place this key in
here sir
goodbye no I'll be funny if it got up to
the second floor and then instead of the
key it's just a grilled cheese sandwich
okay call the elevate call the thingy
yeah there's a key in there Thanks wait
what did you see that the animation
showed it coming from above yes whatever
I mean it's like a tube yeah you never
know what's going on in the tubes you
know like Willy Wonka's glass elevator
tube city yeah it's up to the tubes now
the tubes know what to do
alright so now we're going back I've
already killed these zombies which is
nice so should be easily easy sailing
saw the phrase easy sailing
he sounds like Dirty Harry yeah I think
his scowl also I think it's good that
guess that Clint Eastwood I still think
Clint Eastwood for sure Billy Coen here
2 for 3 con your [ __ ] okay so I have
a key now and I can get in something
sharp okay so get in conductors in here
as a zombie okay good that's good
whoo - so I can't combine these so I
have to send them to her she's
interesting and she's also kind of
injured so that's good
oops so I'm mapping the wall back there
toward the camera okay the key card for
the driver compartment is in my bag as
always if it was a normal key someone
would be sure to turn it in but this is
different
I'll look forward to but we happen to
find it hand it in got it or you check
the bag I mean I check the bag
what's the bun do we're gonna push you
this weed
okay so we got a map of the Train
doesn't say where the girl is which is
interesting
he's on a different floor so oh no she's
no yes that's she yes she's in the
second floor
got it oh then never mind the animation
was right earlier sorry I just making
fun of the game for no reason there's a
red button on the wall was that - I
don't know I'm gonna real fast I'm gonna
examine this - he said there were two
peoples that look like something could
go object you mean like a key no round
object keys can be round it's not
something you have right now sounds like
a key yes
oh that that both looked and sounded
real nice mm-hmm the satisfying click -
yes rungs
I'm in the bar I feel like it's very
much Billy's nature to have a drink
Mediterranean style shrimp
he just gets he climbs up into the bar
just takes away for the year to come
home
carpaccio roast chicken up oh [ __ ] what
is that he's cut scenes really don't
waste time
[Music]
ah goddamn it
oh we got camera get little sneaky
sneaky so they always do this don't wet
the bed there's a round object I see
oh that's the thingy what's that noise
where are your precious [ __ ] so right
now you could just go back and give that
to oh so you're saying don't progress
here I don't even know if you can whoa
item town save ribbons to theirs oh I
don't have enough room for all this
stuff like not even close like I'm super
full well okay but keep in mind you can
drop stuff like do you need your I don't
need this briefcase I don't even know
what to do with it so I would leave that
yeah I can't combine herbs so I think
I'd leave the red because I'm gonna give
it to her anyway
I need to give her the ice pick so I
have to keep that in fact now that I'm
thinking about it I should always give
her both herbs green and red and I
should take this health spray because I
can't combine I must like you're at
yellow and you just want to get two
green that he could use a green right
okay but I see your logic is sound I
think I could use right now bullets yes
yeah he could for sure I don't think I
need it unless I'm going after that
scratchy thing can you go through that
closet door right there sure no but I
could
don't worry about that ink ribbons bring
up your map quick I just want to see
what these all look like oh they are a
different color so ammo is yellow it
looks like so it tells you oh sweet an
item is yellow green is this herb okay
so that's good Natalie does tell you
this okay it was cool for some reason
something and it didn't
okay I don't think you can traverse the
hallway past this point so I think I
think you should get the shotgun okay
I'm gonna take it oh it's two spaces
okay
let's talk about this I'd have to get
rid of both my health
oops [ __ ] I keep I've done this so many
times I can do this I just have to get
rid of both my health or the knife now
the health works you're on good health
anyway yeah I'm doing great
oh but I also have to get the ammo so
I'm gonna leave the bullets too I mean
you don't need to take the shotgun
around what I can't leave my bullets why
not
is it like a the room is full I forgot
that's a part of it too
all right so now that I've taken the gun
I should be able to pick it up right you
should be able to drop something else
okay well would you press triangle there
you go
oh that wasn't on purpose but that's
nice too
all right so I'm gonna drop this say
maybe that touch shotgun Inc Alex the
florist don't fall I think you're fine
if you yep it only holds two shells the
double barrel all right whatever I'm
gonna leave are we on the same page
about this
I'm gonna give her the ice pick and
that's where we're gonna like progress
from because when she is the ice pick
and she can leave [ __ ] I hate this I'll
actually [ __ ] into your space what not
to be that guy the studio might need to
be in use in like five minutes we're
gonna be done in like five minutes
but that's something you'll you might
want to save after this no no I'm saying
I know I have a plan okay I don't have a
plan I don't have a plan I wasn't ready
for this oh it's Shaka or leave yeah
can you leave yeah but I think but I
have to go through here yeah
Oh oh [ __ ] wait can you leave through
that door did I just waste those bullets
yeah he's in my [ __ ] way and I can't
save over here like I can't progress can
i I mean I guess you just gotta I gotta
get the shotgun shells I need to kill it
right yeah and I can't I mean you could
use your handgun if you don't need the
shotgun but yes I do
I'm hon yes you can't drop that key drop
you can't drop the I can't [ __ ] drop
anything let me try again
I just keep accidentally leaving this
space I mean your best bets - I don't
think it's I don't know I don't know if
his health would reset like it then the
other games yeah just hand got him I
just move around you got there's nowhere
to move it's huge
but ya Buer still able to move
this sucks just [ __ ] light them up
yeah check me out I don't think you can
even hit you you ready in nice nice
I think he's gonna miss you
but yeah you should we look don't you
ever get tired being wrong
alright that sounded good I'm gonna no
keep in mind Billy to take a shits on a
damage run you idiot can this thing die
aim I think you're better off famous
down there you go this is like not good
yeah Haga he's just dying noise where's
he sound up yeah he's dead
nice job oh yeah yay now you didn't even
take damage like you can take a lot but
now you might wanna go get that step I
have like no [ __ ] ammo I'm saying I'm
gonna go get back okay so he's dead yeah
alright what we need to leave what if I
save less I'm saying go get the stuff
you need right now I really don't even
think you took any damage I could be
right I only have one free space with
after all that I mean you got your knife
if you run into a regular zombie right
yeah yeah yeah
okay so I have the ice pick
[Music]
Jimmy take the shotgun shells well yeah
because I have the shotgun yeah and I'll
use the knife and only use the shotgun
if I need it
sure and then I'll give her we really
should save though before you even get
to Rebecca on the way back I can't now
because I'm full you remember you left
the ribbons in that other room next to
the typewriter I can't take the ribbons
I am full well we have to get out of
here yeah but I have to go through the
process now where I give her the thingy
no I I see what you're saying or I have
to drop something in that other room
which I think I can do yeah just do that
oh my god I can't take this what do you
go there's that oh no that's so just
remember that's there that's to open
that hatch wait how do I leave yes
that's to open the thing I thought was
the service elevator got it here's like
gonna be a lot of trading in this game
yeah okay so I'm leaving mm-hmm I've got
an ice pick but the first thing I'm
gonna do is save and then we know
exactly what to do when we start the
next up we got a few things we get you
okay
it should be this one yeah okay all
right we're getting there so I'm gonna
drop my ice pick
I know whatever you want yeah maybe what
is it a key item or something here are
you [ __ ] kidding me
try the shotgun shows yeah that's weird
I like [ __ ] can I go save this game
until I save her know it like worst case
we'll leave the ps4 running just make
sure no one turns it off I how did this
happen I hope there's no zombies I'm
like runnin and gunnin to get this done
in is why I like doing this show at the
end of the day because we can like chill
out whereas like there's all these
people like trying to do their jobs
right now it's very inconvenient yeah
sorry it's a crazy week it's okay I
can't I don't think I'm gonna be
recording next week because you're out
of town right I'm here Monday I'm out of
town okay
well didn't I don't know if you want to
do weekend stuff but okay we can figure
it out okay all right dude let's bring
in brews
just kidding okay so now I'm gonna go
save and she can go pick it up later
sure okay no you know you can just fast
swap with triangle oh yeah I'm just
afraid that's gonna set off a course of
events okay do you know what I mean yeah
I don't think this particular case will
but I get what you're saying
got it we just need to remember that the
first thing we do oh god don't be a
cutscene okay I have like no ammo I'd
rather not use shotgun shells like on a
zombie
I have to use my knife yes what you
doubt which I can do it's all possible
man oh that like giant crab
you have to attack its head for massive
damage yeah I couldn't even tell if it
was doing damage when you weren't
shooting downward no I think you were
I'm here to go like you know like that
noise were like a bullet misses yeah
pick it up pick it up pick it up take it
yes so I'm wondering if the room was
just full or if you can't just drop ammo
maybe you have to give those directly to
somebody we're gonna need to learn cuz
that's gonna hurt us later
that I couldn't drop that stuff off how
you feeling so far about zero
interesting I really like the idea of
like switching characters I wonder if
it's gonna be the kind of thing where
it's not really puzzly but it's more
like I gotta change characters to do
this which is annoying but I think
because you can hot-swap really quickly
that will make it easier yeah sick all
right that's one episode in the can
sweet we're back Knievel is back
zero yeah we didn't waste any time sowed
one let's do it
thank you guys for watching enjoy the
rest of your weekend or watch tomorrow
or today today as it were so yeah
because no it's tomorrow
today this is the closest to
[Music]